en el congreso de eeuu hay un plan de
infraestructura de 12 billones de
dólares que se aprobaría aproximadamente
si los demócratas que tienen la mayoría
se ponen de acuerdo
un plan que incluso republicanos como
marco rubio apoya la buena estructura es
importante y apoyo eso siempre y cuando
sea sobre puentes y muelles y carretera
pero yo tan invirtiendo en toda una
serie de otras cosas que no se trata de
mientras tanto a cada hogar
estadounidense le cuesta en promedio
tres mil trescientos dólares al año los
gastos asociados al mal estado de la
infraestructura según la sociedad de
ingenieros civiles de eeuu
el reciente descarrilamiento de uno de
los trenes del metro de washington hizo
que el 60% de los vagones fueron
retirados del sistema para su revisión
para muchos esto significó más demoras y
más planeación para llegar a tiempo a
sus trabajos de tren en la edad de los
trenes la edad de las vías férreas el
estado de los túneles en el reporte
cuatrienal de la sociedad de ingenieros
civiles de eeuu la infraestructura del
país ha sido evaluada con un c - según
emily central directora de iniciativas
de la organización el mal estado de la
infraestructura es consecuencia de la
falta de inversión de gobiernos
anteriores
el principal problema de la
infraestructura en eeuu se reduce a la
falta de financiación si usted toma solo
el ejemplo del impuesto a la gasolina
que es el que financia muchas de
nuestras vías puentes y sistemas de
tránsito este no ha subido desde el año
eeuu está en el penúltimo lugar entre
los países del g20 en cuanto a
porcentaje del producto interno bruto
invertido en infraestructura según el
foro económico mundial y según
de ingenieros civiles si el país no paga
la factura vencida en infraestructura
perdería 10 billones de dólares en
crecimiento económico y 3 millones de
empleos para el 2030 y 9